this
is my nephew junyun
he's five years old super adorable
i asked him the other day what would you
like for your birthday this year
he said i want to have a one-way mirror
spider-man mask
i had absolutely no idea what he was
talking about so i said
well it's really cool but how are you
gonna get it
he told me without a blinks of his eyes
i'm gonna tell my mom
and make her wish before i go to bed
my mom will go to shake her mobile phone
the next morning
the delivery uncle will give it to me
when i wake up
i was about to tease him but suddenly i
realized
he was simply telling me the truth the
truth
of what shopping looks like for this
generation
if you think of it for a child like
uanum
shopping is a very different idea
compared to what my generation had in
mind
shopping is always done on mobile and
payment
is all virtual a huge
shopping revolution is happening in
china right now
shopping behaviors and also technology
platforms have evolved differently than
elsewhere in the world
for instance e-commerce in china is
soaring
it's been growing at twice the speed of
the united states and a lot of the
growth
is coming from mobile every month
500 million consumers
are buying our mobile phones and to put
that into context
that is the total population of the
united states
uk germany combined
but it is not just about the scale of
the e-commerce
it is a speed of adoption and the
aggregation of the ecosystems
it took china less than five years to
become a country of mobile commerce
and that is largely because of the two
technology platforms
alibaba and the tencent they own 90
percent
of the e-commerce pretty much the whole
market
85 of social media 85
of internet payment and they also own
large volume
of digital content video
online movie literature travel
information
gaming when this huge
base of mobile shoppers meets with
aggregated ecosystems
chemical reactions happen today china is
like a huge laboratory
generating all sorts of experiments you
should come to china
because here you will get a glimpse into
the future
one of the trends i have seen concerns
the spontaneity of shopping
five years ago in a fashion study we
found that on average
a chinese consumer will be buying five
to eight pairs of shoes
this number tripled to reach about 25
pairs of shoes a year
who would need so many pairs of shoes
so i asked them what are the reasons you
buy
they told me a list of inspirations
blogs
celebrity news fashion informations
but really for many of them there was no
particular reason to buy
they were just browsing on their mobile
site and then
buying whatever they saw we have
observed
the same level of spontaneity in
everything
from grocery shopping to buying
insurance products
but it is not very difficult to
understand if you think about it
a lot of the chinese consumers are still
very new in their middle class
or upper middle class lifestyle with a
strong desire
to buy everything new new products new
services
and with this integrated ecosystem it is
so easy for them to buy
one click after another
however this new shopping behavior is
creating a lot of challenges
for those once dominant businesses the
owner of a fashion company
told me that is so frustrated because
his customers keeps complaining that his
products are not new enough
well for a fashion company really bad
comment
and he already increased the number of
products in each collection
doesn't seem to work so i told him
there's something more important than
that you've got to give your consumer
exactly what they want when they still
want it
and he can learn something from the
online apparel players
in china these companies they collect
real consumer feedback from mobile sites
from social media
and then their designers will translate
these information
into product ideas and then send them to
micro studios
for production these micro studios are
really key
in this overall ecosystem because they
take small orders
30 garments at a time and they can also
make
partially customized pieces the fact
that all these
productions designed are done locally
the whole process
from transporting to product on shelf or
online
sometimes takes only three to four days
that is super fast
and that is highly responsive to what is
in and hot on the market
and that is giving enormous headaches to
traditional retailers
who are only thinking about a few
collections a year
then there's a consumer's need for ultra
convenience
a couple months ago i was shopping with
a friend in tokyo
we were in the store and there was three
to four people standing in front of us
at the checkout counter pretty normal
right
but both of us dropped out selection and
walked away
this is how impatient we have become
delivering outro convenience is not just
something nice to have
it is crucial to make sure your consumer
actually buy
and in china we have learned that
convenience is really the glue that will
make online shopping a behavior
and a habit that sticks it is sometimes
more effective than a loyalty program
alone
take huma it's a retail grocery concept
developed by alibaba they deliver a full
basket of products from 4 000
skus to your doorstep within 30 minutes
what is amazing is that they deliver
literally everything
fruits vegetables of course they also
deliver
live fish and also live alaska king crab
like my friend once told me it's really
my dream coming true
finally i can impress my mother-in-law
when she comes to visit me for dinner
unexpectedly
well companies like amazon and the fresh
direct are also experimenting in the
same field
the fact that roma is part of the
alibaba ecosystem
makes it faster and also a bit easier to
implement
for an online grocery player it is very
difficult
very costly to deliver a full basket
quickly
but for huma it's got a mobile app it's
got
mobile payment and also it's built 20
physical stores in high density areas in
shanghai
these stores are built to ensure the
freshness of the products
they actually have fish tanks in the
store and also to give locations that
will enable
high-speed delivery i know the question
you have on your mind
are they making money yes they are
making money they are breaking even
and what is also amazing is that the
sales revenue per store is three to four
times
higher than the traditional grocery
store and half of the revenue
orders are coming from mobile this is
really a proof
that by consumer if you give them out
your convenience they really want in
grocery shopping
they're gonna switch their shopping
behaviors online like in no time
so ultra convenience and spontaneity
that's not the full story the other
trend i have seen in china
is social shopping if you think of
social shopping
elsewhere in the world it is a linear
process
you pick up something on facebook
watched it
and you switch to amazon or brand.com to
complete the shopping journey
clean and simple but in china it is a
very different thing
on average a consumer would spend one
hour
on their mobile phone shopping that's
three times higher than the united
states
where does the stickiness come from what
are they actually doing
on this tiny little screen so let me
take you on a mobile shopping journey
that i usually would be experiencing
11 pm yes that's usually when i shop
i was having a chat in wechat chat room
with my friends
one of them took out a pack of snack and
the posted
the product link in that chat room paid
it
because usually i would just click that
link and then
land on the product page lots of
information
very colorful mind-blowing watched it
and then a shop assistant came online
and asked me how can i help you tonight
of course i bought that pack of snack
what is more beautiful is i know
that the next day around noon time that
pack of snap will be delivered to my
office
i can eat it and share it with my
colleagues and the cost of delivery
maximum one dollar just when i was about
to leave that shopping site
another screen popped up this time
it is the live streaming of a grassroots
celebrity
teaching me how to wear a new color of
lipstick
i watched for 30 seconds very easy to
understand
and also there's a shopping link right
next to it
clicked it bought it in a few seconds
back to the chat room the gossiping is
still going on
another friend of mine posted the qr
code of another pack of snack
clipped it bought it so the whole
experience
is like you are exploring in the main in
amusement park
is chaotic it is fun and it's
even a little bit addictive this is
what's happening
when you have this integrated ecosystem
shopping
is embedded in social and it's social
it's evolving
into a multi-dimensional experiences the
integration of ecosystem
reaches a whole new level so does its
dominance
in all aspects of our life
and of course there are huge commercial
opportunities behind it
a chinese stat company sri squirrel
built a half a billion dollar business
in just three years by investing in 300
to 500
shop assistants who's going to be online
to provide services
24 7. in the social media environment
they're like your neighborhood friends
even when you're not buying stuff
they'll be happy to just tell you a few
jokes and make you happy
in this integrated ecosystem social
media can really redefine
the relationship between brands retailer
and consumer these are only
fragments of the massive changes i have
seen in china
in this huge laboratory a lot of
experiments are generated
every single day the ecosystems
are reforming supply chain distribution
marketing product innovation everything
consumers are giving back the power to
decide what they want to buy
when they want to buy it how they want
to buy it how they want to social
it is now back to business leaders of
the world
to really open their eyes see what's
happening in china
think about it and take actions
thank you
angela what you share with us is truly
impressive and almost incredible but i
think
many in the audience had the same
question that
i had which is is this kind of
impulsive consumption both
economically and environmentally
sustainable over the longer term and
what is the total price um to be paid
for such an atomized and ultra
convenient retail experience
yeah one thing we have to keep in mind
is really we are at the very beginning
of a huge transformation so with this
trading up needs of the consumer
together with the evolution of the
ecosystem
there are a lot of opportunities and
also challenges
so i've seen some early signs that the
ecosystems
are shifting their focus to pay
attention to solve these challenges
for example paying more considerations
to sustainability
alongside just about speed and also
quality
over quantity but there are really no
simple answers to these questions
that is exactly why i'm here to tell
everyone that we need to watch it
study it and play a part in this
evolution
so thank you very much thank you
[Music]